strap on your tinfoil hats you guys that
is a pork welcome back to behind the
screens I'm ash cross and I've got my
good friend with me today Steele
Saunders of Steel Wars podcast hey you
guys and what do you think we're talking
about today ports and porks and porks no
we're talking about the last Jedi
trailer because it came out on Monday
night and there is a lot to dissect
theories we watched it together we did
and after eight polish Star Wars films
finally they've got their act together
finally they've got their moment then
we'll cut pogs in space but we watched
it together I broke your couch yeah ash
broke literally broke my couch so go to
this link this is a GoFundMe for Steel's
new couch what we're gonna do today is
go through the trailer and kind of break
it down and theorize what some of these
scenes could mean and what the
unanswered questions are so let's get
right to it so the trailer opens up with
kylo Ren in his some sort of shipyard or
something he's got a nice little buttock
hugging tunic type vibe going there you
know I set this on your podcast it it
kind of reminds me of it's like a weird
Luke parallel to me I feel like they
weren't trying to do that but he's got
like the floppy hair the cinched waist I
see a little bit more Anakin Skywalker
that's also a good point pensively
looking out to the galaxies about to
break you can also see if you look
really closely there's an 80s T the
chicken Walker from oh yeah my Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi so then
they've gotta be too old hardware so
these are the I believe ATM 6 they're
the mega Collider super periscope like I
can't get the name down yet and I have
to learn it before the film is
premiering or before I have a child
because that's their name but the slang
onset for them is called the gorilla
walkers because they've got the
invariant fists and apparently the in
universe reason is so you can't
I'm up but it looks like they're on
Crate ohaf one of the two well I see
like that red red mineral that they kick
up that's that's red space cook it's
there exciting it's a big night I'm
crying that's why I've liked the
resistance is there they're like we've
got a mind the space coat yeah yeah
they're trying to resist but who can and
also very cool looks like you've got a
kylo ren's lander is in the background
there but I like come on Hasbro let's
get a giant box in a toy shop and we can
buy a very expensive bit of plastic that
resembles that in some way now where do
we think that is because it kind of
looks like it could be crate but I feel
like it's like where's like snoke's
layer do you think it's tricky I can
definitely narrow it down to a galaxy
far far away yeah probably a long time
ago I thought this was Wilmington
Delaware no no no wow you know this
could be you are way off but the
interesting thing about this with kylo
Ren and the first thought of
snowtroopers it's a little bit
reminiscent of when Anakin Skywalker
marched into the Jedi Temple at the end
of Revenge of the Sith that's a bit of a
Star Wars ring Theory you know with the
visual poem Ashley right right of course
it all wrong horse
but I'm not sure where this one is it
could be on Krait when you put together
the crate sort of a snowy planet and
kylo ren's lander is there mm-hmm
and there's there's there's the red
elements it's right all over this thing
I know this all of it is red here it's
crazy this is great color and picking up
the lightsabers I'm talking about more
read more read Nelson boy ah we have to
talk about this this is this is my
moment of the trailer earthquake octo
I'm also Luke's reaction mark Hamill's
reaction I'm such a Luke Skywalker fan I
cannot wait to see him in action but his
just Hamill's reaction to the earthquake
and how shocked he is like you know it's
Jedi Master Luke Skywalker and
he's trippin out right at he can't do
the ground crack no he's trying that's
the thing too is like you know when we
saw the teaser and everything we've seen
before he's so like Stern and focused
and doesn't seem like he's scared of her
and then we watch this trailer and he's
freaking terrified
he's a motive he's coming out of his
shell but I think it was JJ Abrams that
said that Hamill should be up for an
Oscar for his portrayal in this film and
that is an Oscar level scaring of seeing
it right Oscar level reaction yeah you
could you could you could put your
Daniel day-lewis in front of a crack and
you wouldn't have a reaction like that
but Hamill has nailed it I think that
cracks there I think it's terrifying
okay so Luke mentions that he's seen
that raw power before and then he kind
of go to this flashback of him in the
destroyed Jedi Order scenario hand
coming out well last night in one of the
podcast I did we we called that the Jedi
gazebo totally ruined by kylo Ren so
he's there in the rubble of the Jedi
gazebo and yeah t800 style coming out
with his robotic end and so obviously
getting some form of flashback that we
saw in raised horseback right in the
force awakens where we got to see the
Jedi Temple or gazebo destroyed I I'm
wondering ash cruisin yeah Entertainment
Tonight huh might we start the movie
with this scene it would be interesting
because obviously we're gonna get a
pretty big section of a flashback and
it's it doesn't seem like it's gonna be
that quick kind of force back where it's
like here's a bunch of images it seems
like we're getting like a full scene of
a flashback but they've never done that
they've never been like but that's
Kathleen Kennedy's Lucasfilm yeah so
let's let's fire all the directors but
the thing with the film for those who
don't know the force awakens ended with
the handover of the lightsaber and then
we're going to see the conclusion of
that scene so what a fans are wondering
what are we going to have in the crawl
is it gonna start straight from that
scene again but I this is my theory is
my first theory I'm dropping that
they're going to go back in time the
crawl is going to describe what's
happening back before the force awakens
and we will see the destruction of the
Jedi gazebo how does that's that's a
theory out there no I like I like a hot
take I like a hot theory you know and if
it comes true I'll be linking to this
video and if not I will be desperately
texting you on December 15 to delete
this bad boy like it's gonna be weird
though yeah what are they gonna do for
the opening croelick here's where we
left off the last movie panned down
lightsaber really did yeah it's just
like you remember that bit here it is
yeah here it is no time yeah that jury I
think of course Rian Johnson no stranger
to time jumps and time travel right we
director with uh yeah we ba thank you go
to IMDB here so I don't know I think I'm
going with it it's let's call it
saunders theory one i would love to hear
what people have to say about this like
what they think the crawls gonna be and
what the first scene is gonna be like is
it gonna be back on october is it gonna
be somewhere else but i do like i don't
i don't hate that those hand gestures i
actually was gonna duck out of the way
of the crow right freaking [ __ ] even
though it does go the other way so it
should be more who the cross okay
moving article all right that's an
important one yes he says that he'd only
seen that type of raw power once before
I seen this roster only once before it
didn't scare me enough then it does now
I'm not afraid you will be you will be
I've seen some things on the internet
today that cuz he like you assume he's
talking about kylo Ren right I do but
I'd been yeah I know where you going
been pointing out that he says he's not
afraid and then Yoda says you will be
hmm that's that's a deep cop it's like
that's that is deep is he comparing her
to Vader and not kylo Ren I heard an
alternate theory okay
now strap on your tinfoil hats you guys
know that is a pork that perhaps Luke
has been with Rey before and there's
some sort of memory wipe going off so
he's saying okay like mm-hmm
I'm not I'm not I'm not locking that
down that's not so unders theory - okay
that's stuff I read on the internet I
want to keep - you know it's a theory
yeah I'm reporting on it John I mean I'm
reporting the crime I didn't perpetrate
the crime understandable understandable
but again if it does come true we're
gonna have to read this it's true I
think the audio you know all the lines
and this this trailer are almost more
like I want to dissect those more
because it's like who is Snoke talking
to who is Luke talking to like because
Snoke saying when I found you you know I
saw raw you know untamed power could he
be talking about Rey saying he found her
as a child or is he talking about kylo
this is the thing with Rian Johnson's
trailer there is misdirection on top of
misdirection
so the initial trailer your initial
thought is that the that Snoke is
talking about kylo Ren then if you like
like semi savvy you go no it's actually
right right but then it could be a
double back
Jona main like I tell you the truth
because I think you think I'm gonna be
lying that's really the truth so you go
the wrong way you know he's talking to
Luke maybe saying when I found you and
we destroyed your temple oh my god like
previously in Star Wars obi-wan Kenobi
was the biggest liar in the galaxy but I
think he's been bumped by the delightful
Rian Johnson mm-hmm that's sona's theory
too so we got to talk about the kylo Ren
Leia face-off
because I think I think this moment is
gonna happen I think she senses him he's
probably tasked with killing her but
they never show him you know pushing the
button mm-hmm mm-hmm
so does he do it the theory sort of
links in with the end of the trailer I
think that perhaps in the final second
where he has to decide because it
flashes to his face he's having a lot of
issues with it
yeah he seems to be having a harder time
at shooting his mum ship then he had at
shipping his dad's got Jonah me unless
his dad ignited the lightsaber nor that
he's now you've got the tinfoil poor gun
I have interviewed the editor of the
force awakens and when I told him that
theory he was upset that he'd done his
job badly that anyone could possibly
have that theory he was sad you made him
sad I'm sad you made him sad people like
you made himself come up with it I'm
just reporting uh here we go I'm just
reporting what I heard sources say
sources say this could have been the
case
YouTube sources say no no no so I'm
thinking that perhaps at the last
because we all this is what I'm willing
to that could we get a partial or a grey
redemption of kylo Ren in
the last Jedi and perhaps at the last
moment he does pull away he shoots at
something else to save later ship and
then perhaps he helps cuz i when when if
just say Snoke is complimenting rey on
her power and kylo ren's in the room if
you have a little thing called jealousy
hmm no never well you know how there's
those giant pogs that people want okay
see now she's remembering jealousy so
this could be the start of kylo ren's
sort of like by the end of the film
there could be like the good guys Snoke
in the first order and then Rey and
color Ren together
confused with the force just another
theory just throwing them out there yeah
let's throw them out that's hey that's
what that's what we do here I just part
of me thinks that kylo Ren is just so
unredeemable at this point you know that
by saving his mom by turning his back on
the first order at this point what could
his face there I mean he could he could
pool you know a Vader at the end of
Return of the Jedi you know mm-hmm but
people sort of be expect it to happen in
Episode nine and the marketing of
Episode eight is to expect the
unexpected which means now I'm expecting
or expecting a huge twist and then
they're just not gonna be one and the
twist is that there is no twist Oh
double twist words gone like I don't
think Ryan will do that I think he's
think he's got a twinkle in his eye I
think that I don't think it's a non
twist twist
I think it's a twist twist twist twist
twist twist yeah like we're expecting
there not to be a twist cuz we thought
there was gonna twist but now there's
gonna be a twist yeah he said in an
interview that I'm now making up that he
wrote the script to chubby Checker's do
the twist
[Applause]
okay this is the pong it's his fault
that my couch is broken
I've never screamed so loud in my life
also I love it he's like imitating
Chewbacca oh yeah well it's a great
thing is Chewbacca scream POG scream we
all scream and they might catch cash
yeah living spaces if you're watching I
would help a brother out because these
couches don't repair themselves Wow
we're reaching out to specific brands
for allagash wait can I have some beer
but how good these little teeth somebody
posed a question to me today that really
messed me up
what do pours eat a little teeth I've
heard a rumor this is this is spec
speculation inform speculation cool I
think Chewbacca is gonna have a little
bit of issues with them getting in the Y
and I sure sure yeah Roger seems like
maybe he like befriends one you know
what you come somebody oh my gosh I wish
I could remember I'm gonna put the tweet
here when I find it
somebody said today the pores if they do
have names one should be named Gary
after carrie fisher's dog Gary oh I
thought that was a wonderful idea if
they have names and one definitely
should be called ash after my friend in
Australia Oh - he's a great guy now this
this showdown between Finn and phasma
first of all is gonna be amazing it's
like kind of a light saber esque battle
but without light sabers but if you look
kind of closely in the background you
can see there's Walker's on the side
there's Tie Fighters in the background
I'm thinking it's that same place that
maybe kylo Ren was overlooking in the
beginning of the trailer it definitely
has a similar look and then you know Poe
Dameron makes this line about how he can
light up the first order so maybe you
know he's attacking finns in there
because he's undercover they got to have
this showdown they got to get
out of there oh my god I hope that oh
man what if Finn goes down no there's no
way no I think we know Finn is in there
undercover yeah he's he's in there with
with ROS ROS Tico who doesn't
she is so undercover in the last Jedi
that she doesn't even make an appearance
in the trailer no not the new characters
do we don't get DJ we don't get holder
we don't get ROS we don't even see
Huck's we get we get Gary the POG he's a
what we do Gary mm-hmm Gary the other
thing we don't get is those the the
nurses the caretaker the caretaker nuns
the the turtles in dresses right I kind
of like to see them in action so that I
can feel better about them yeah what
sort of action do you think they're
possibly gonna be saving by action I
just mean like moving in general or like
doing some things because right now I
imagine them just having rulers and be
like look they broke a lot of rulers
earlier or like the pores are chewing on
his hand Gary stop Wow our head Canon is
getting out of control I would love to
see ray being trained by Luke and in the
background you can just see them like
sweeping this sweeping grass like you
really see people we know I and they're
sweeping their could look at the front
of their house
right I'm just like oh my god to have
that much free time right we've got time
to sweep your room clean like let alone
my curb outside who cares but yeah we're
talking about people with their wives
kind of together and also there's an
awesome shot here i ôm very know
reflective expense that in phasma's
helman you can see you know Finn can fix
his hair actors chillin hey there it is
I did take a closer look at this today
cuz it that's that's freakin awesome
that's such a beautiful shot that looks
like the same place as that the battle
goes down when the first order is all
standing there lined up that's like the
exact same location and you've got that
shot of Ray diving in water and then
we've also seen some
work released that there's an x-wing in
the water next to the island oh yeah oh
she's duck dive and to get the keys out
or there's a spare battery down there
she's got an iPhone but I I think she's
definitely going into the water to get
something looks like a skull on the
right oh yeah there's a dead something
in there good pickup ash hey I think
that's pretty casing snark bending right
like a banana she's done her Jedi
Pilates I feel like the question is like
how does she get there is she go does
she go with kylo Ren because it's it
would seem silly if she got kidnapped
again
oh yeah that would I I'm not into that
at all I think I don't know in my head
I'm saying that she goes to Luke Luke
wants no part of it he sort of gets
bugged into a bit of training and the
training goes too well freaks him out he
sees the crack you know he reacts Oscars
in the bag then Rey bails by herself
seeking you know just you know she says
at the end she just wants to find her
place in all of this and you know maybe
Snoke can you know tries to tempt her
with with a place in this because we
time een we've been talking about how
the the trailer is probably a mystery
cuz the whole trailer is like Luke goes
to trainer he's like very scared of her
sons turn away she can't find her place
goes with kylo Ren and then ends up with
Snoke
I feel like the scene with kylo Ren and
Rey talking is not actually them talking
to each other it seems mr. Ekta it just
doesn't it doesn't feel right
it feels misdirect II but it also feels
so meand it's so it's such a it's such
if it's not if it is a misdirect it is
such a giant misdirect right that but it
isn't that playing and just what
everybody has been saying they're like
rates gonna go to the dark side Ray's
gonna go that's like the number one
theory that people throw around besides
like her Parenthood
like you know what I have a hard time it
is like if you look at Ray's face you
know there's a fire and there is like
there's a light source coming from the
same side you throw in a two-shot
there's no ash falling behind her it
just doesn't seem like the same place
and there is the interesting factor of
kylo ren's scar
you know the band-aid isn't there so I
don't know what point or one thing we
haven't considered it's not a misdirect
but it's a vision it could be because
she does seem so okay I'm this is coming
together as I think about these she has
got her beginning of the film outfit on
with the collar I have been on the
internet all night
like discussing this with my collar
experts right and they say that color is
from the resistance rate right Jason
Ward said that yeah he's my color expert
for making Star Wars don't know you guys
and then so you've got Rey in a costume
that she ends the force awakens with
begins the last Jedi with and then
you've got kylo Ren with post space
Nellie band-aid mm-hmm
so they're they're two different things
about perhaps if it's a vision then all
bets are off in these visions my final
question here did do you think the
trailer revealed too much no I agree I
think it just like you've got the pot it
just putting some hot peppers stirred
all around turn up the heat and now it's
is bubbling and it's overflowing into
YouTube content is I mean like we were
saying you know they threw in a lot of
possibilities whether or not they're
misdirecting we'll find out but there's
so many new characters that are
apparently have a big role mm-hmm got DJ
Benicio del Toro yeah yeah you've got um
Laura Dern if that Rose Tico who is
apparently Brian Johnson said the
biggest of the new cast members yeah so
the trail really focused on the force
users right and in the mysteries of the
force but what we do know
is that Finn and Rose gonna go to canter
by which is kind of like the Monte Carlo
plant the casino planet which I don't
even think they showed I not not a hint
yeah and so that is a giant chunk of the
film not there
we know pose gonna look out a window
right not enough PO hmm that you know
he'll be smoldering in December I'm sure
so there is a lot of things not covered
so I think they did and and and also if
there are a lot of mr. X then we don't
know we don't know anything it's it's a
right Johnson's gonna like hold off on
all those TV spots because that's what
ends up happening they like this is
great we're good and then they add a
bunch of trailers and all of a sudden
I'm like oh I've seen way too much yeah
just use the same footage for the TV
spots you need extra footage yeah if you
need like TV footage to get you to go
then you haven't watched this so try
this again yeah
come on Lucasfilm just repeat come on
come on all right thank you so much for
coming in my pleasure Ashley cruisin
tell everyone where they can find you
well if you're on YouTube which you
already are you can go to my channel
youtube.com forward slash steel wars
there'll be a link and you can see the
video of one ash cruisin breaking my
couch that's true it is mid Paul gas you
can hear the crack you actually can hear
it break and it breaks we realize it
breaks and then we just continue
watching the trailer because you're in
the middle of the trailer you're gonna
stop the pucks the couch it's like this
is the Star Wars trailer airing right
now and if you just want stuff your ears
you should check out the steel wars
podcasters to star wars podcast every
week and one of them's a new show one of
them's an interview show which Ashley's
been on and been on it and even
Entertainment Tonight Legend alumni
Leonard Moulton's been on the show hey
Leonard so check that out at steel walls
comm iTunes or wherever good audio
content is downloaded freely oh hey and
you guys can leave in the comments below
what your hopes and dreams are for the
last Jedi do you think too much was
revealed what didn't you want to see
what did you love about the trailer just
Chuck that all down here or you can
tweet us our Twitter handles will be
right here I assume and which which
theory do you think we'll be keeping and
which will be deleted on December 15
like oh god not that one not that one
that one thank you guys so much for
watching see you next week next time
whenever bye love you mean it may the
porks be with you may that force be with
you
hey the porks be with you they're with
us